(upbeat music)
- I remember the first time we got on
a start line, and it’s just adrenaline.
Blood was pumping, heart rate was racing.
Being on a sidecar does
add that extra dimension
because you've got to work
with the person next to you.
Having him as my brother in a sidecar
is what it's all about.
- I'm Sam Houghton.
- I'm Andy Houghton.
- We're brothers.
- And we're a competitive
sidecarcross team.
I started racing probably
when I was about 10.
I'd been on a bike since four years old.
Oh there you go that's
a mean look isn't it?
I was maybe 13 in that picture.
Sam beat me once.
- In the last race that we had.
- No yeah, yeah
- [Sam] Well, you know
- But you still only,
- [Sam] as your last race.
- you still only,
still ever only beaten me once.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- Won my first championship
with the local club.
About 11 or 12 years old, rode my bike
all the way up through
different championships
till I was 24 in 2005 and
that's when I had my accident.
I had an accident while
I was out training.
I ended up going over the handle bars and,
and landing flat on my back,
shattered my T7 vertebrae.
That one moment kind of changed my life.
I came out of hospital
and then I spent a couple
of years without, without doing much.
There’s only so long that you can fend off
that desire and that bug
to get back on a bike.
We found a sidecar and now I'm out
racing this thing, which is fantastic.
When I tell people that I race sidecar
they seem to assume that I'm gonna
be the one in the passenger side but
that's not the case, I'm on the bike.
The guys in the sidecar,
there's no sitting.
There’s no sitting at all,
they're throwing themselves
from left to right and you've
gotta be fully able-bodied.
- My role on the team is effectively
to turn the bike and to keep it level.
To do that it's a case of chucking
your weight from side to side.
If Andrew wants to go one way,
and I'm not on the same wavelength,
we're not going that way.
- Most of the time he knows what I'm gonna do.
As brothers you've probably got that,
that relationship a little bit
closer than you would otherwise.
That feeling you get
when you're out on the track,
for me it's, it's what I live for.
Keep, you get it banked into a corner
and you've got the bike drifting sideways.
I'm out there and no one knows
that I'm in a wheelchair.
No one knows.
You're just one of the guys,
you're a sidecar racer.
You're not a disabled guy,
and it just is an amazing feeling.